小伙伴们大家好,我是本次直播课程的讲师郭一鹏
很高兴和大家在看训练营马力全开特辑的直播间见面
2626的看训练营我们设置了全新的四大主题课程
有看基础系列,马力全开特辑,开发者说,企业对话专场
同时也设置了更多好玩的互动让各位小伙伴参与
给大家介绍一下本季全新的训练营玩法,大家可以先截图保存
玩法一,看直播的同时,大家可以扫码到社区活动页,边看边答题
全部回答正确的前五名小伙伴可领取奖品
玩法二,课后作业,在直播的课程结束后
一旧也会更新另外的三道题目
全部回答正确的前五名小伙伴可以领取定制茅团
玩法三是学习笔记和直播打卡
按要求在圣腾论坛发布学习心得,并且提交issue
既有机会获得社区的定制礼品
好,回到正题
本次课程的主题是从基础理论到实践
全流程掌握面向圣腾的Tradenson的开发
首先呢,我也是给大家介绍一下我们Tradenson的基本原理
以及说Tradenson这种编程前段是如何在生存上运行的
第一个我们要了解就是说,为什么大家需要Tradenson这么一种算子的编程语言
首先呢,我们要了解就是说开发者呢
他对于不同的场景下,他跟算子的编程的需求其实是有不一样的
像有的场景下呢,可能开发者对于这个开发的效率
比如说我开发同一个算子的速度来说,对大家这个是最重要的一点
他对这个性能的要求呢,相对来说就没有那么高
只要保持在一个较高的性能就可以
那第二类的这个编程倾向呢,就是说
我其实我愿意花时间,更多的时间去来对这个算子做深入的优化
但是我希望这个算子呢,可以达到一个极致的性能
那针对这两种不同的场景呢,其实开发者呢,就需要来选用不同的这种开发方式
对第一来说呢,比如说如果开发者,他是搞一些算法研究的一些研究者
那他需要拿最快的速度来完成他的这个想法的一个验证
或者说呢,想用一个新模型的一个算子定制
对大家说他需要用最快的速度把这个圆形给打通
或者说对有的这个场景来说呢,他需要把同一套算子来部署到不同的平台上
这样的话呢,开发者需要说尽可能的避免同一个算子面向于多种的硬件去做重复的开发
还有的情况就是说这个算子本身呢,他在这个网络里并不是性能的瓶颈
他对于功能来说非常的关键
但是呢,他在整个网络中的时间占比非常小
或者说性能挖掘的潜力比较低
这个情况下呢,我们就不需要再投太多的精力去做他的一个性能优化
再另外就是说,对于这个,如果说这个开发者呢
他是一个新来到这个AI算子这个领域
或者说他是一个学生
他又很难通过对这个有足够的经验去做编写这种极致性能的算子
那对于这类的开发者来说呢
他又比较适合用这种高效开发的这个方式来完成他的算子编程
但是还有一部分场景呢,比如说他是基础库的开发维护
那这种库里的算子呢,都是在模型中被频繁的调用
对整体的性能影响非常的明显
或者说他在这个整网里呢,他是一个算子这个性能的瓶颈
那对于这种算子呢,我们就需要就是描定他去做一个深入的优化
去突破他的性能
再或者这个场景他可能本来就是需要的是这种超低的延迟
比如自动价值这个场景
那我们就是需要对性能来满足他最高要求
那另外就是对这种开发方式来说呢
他其实需要这个开发者有充足的这个算子开发经验
而且呢他还需要这个对这个硬价有这个足够的了解
来支撑他就是通过这个硬价的特性来完成他这个算子的这个极致优化
那这两种方式呢,其实并不是互斥的
其实是可以搭配来使用的
比如说如果我搞创新的时候
可以首先用第一种方式来快速的实现
我们这个整体的算法创新
来把这个开发的效率红利给享受到
然后呢我们在实现了原型之后
再识别说里边哪些算子是这个关键的热点算子
或者说性能表现不佳的算子
然后我们再用第二种方式去对他做这个性能的一个极致调用
那这个就是我们整体上大概大致分类上的两种不同的编程算子需求
那Traten呢他就是属于这个最典型的第一类的编程需求
他有比较高的开发效率
同时呢又有相对来说很高的性能
那下面就是来解释下为什么说Traten他是可以做到这个开发效率
要优于这个相对来说这种C类语言
那首先我们要了解释Traten他的分类上他属于一种跳级的编程方式
他呢本身是面向于GPU来设计的一种编程语言
所以说我们这块也对应着概念来过一过
首先我们对算别人来说
那我们抽象层次最高的一种
就是说我们对于这个数据
我们其实并不会给他做任何的处理
一整个Tensor给我们
我们就直接对这个整个Tensor来做这个数学的运算
运算完了就是就结束了
那我们现在说整个实验过程里是关注他数学逻辑的实现
那这个抽象层次是最高的
那么往下降一层呢
就是说我们控制的是这个对数据来说
我们会控制他的这个分块和他这个分块之间的并行是过来实现的
然后说呢
但除了这个以外
另外就需要就是把数据从以片外的内存搬到片上内存
数字之外其他的部分
也都是就是关注集中在这个数学逻辑的实现就可以
那对这种降一降级的层次的这个抽象层次的语言来说呢
他就是比TensorLevel要多了一些细节
但是跟硬件并不是完全的这种强相关硬莽定的一种一种逻辑
然后但是呢多了一些这些细节之后呢
就可以把这个性能跟TensorLevel要提升很多
那比这一层我们把这个抽象层次再往下降一级的话
那就是这种ThreadLevel这种
那这种线程级的编程方式呢
就是我们就需要说把控制好这个每一个线程的操作
那这种呢他就是说我的实现上会比前两种要复杂很多
因为需要开发者手动实现的这个硬件细节就是更多了
那这种方式呢因为说有更多的这个硬件的具体的执行是通过开发者来完成的
那对他来说他的这个性能就可以达到最高的一种优化
所以说我们对编程语言的描述KTV
越高抽象的这个编程语言
他在开发的难度上和效率上就难度越低
然后开发效率越高
然后代码行数呢也会越少
同时呢他也不会包含对硬件有特别深入的细节
而越低抽象的这个编程语言呢
他的这个门槛就更高
然后代码呢也更长
现在就难以维护
但是呢因为说开发者可以通过手动的控制硬件的执行期间
那这种方式的编程效率是最高的
而对于高等开发来说呢
像开发者的我们这种对硬件的具体的执行方式
只是说开发者不交开发者来做
但是这种内容呢并不会就是从算子中消失
而是通过编译器来自动的给我们插入
也就是说越高抽象的DSL呢
那编译器的做的工作越多
而越低抽象呢开发者做的工作越多
但对编译器来说呢
他的第一优先级永远是正确性
所以说呢他并不对于一些过于激进的优化方式呢
他其实就可能会放弃掉
为了保证这个算子的正确性
而对开发者来说呢
他就是可以自由地去做这种激进优化
来完成这个硬件
这个整个算子的一个性能的实用提升
那比如说啊
就是我们如果我们对比GPU的CUDA和Triton来说
那如果我们使用CUDA这种C的源开发的话
像这种内存的管理内存的合并
以及这个核内的调度
就全都需要开发者来手工完成
那这样的话呢
开发者的工作量和这个编写算子的难度
就会提升很多
但是呢也是因为多这些细节
算子的效率可以更高
对Triton来说呢
他对于这个
一些这个
比如说
内存的管理和合并
然后包括这个核内的这个调度
其实全是通过编辑来自动完成了
他自己只需要控制我这个核件的调度
也就是说这个分块之间的并行
那这样的话
这样的话Triton他需要写的这个代码就会更少
然后呢就会有更多的内容让编辑来替我们去完成
会有更多的内容让编辑来替我们去完成
那我们参考一下之前Python大会上展触的一个图
对这种三种开发方式来说呢
Triton是出向层次最高的
那其次是Cuda
然后最底层的是SaaS
它是一种会编辑的这种语言
那大家可以看到明显的这种出向层次和这个效率
以及这个性能之间的关系
就是说如果我们只有比较短的时间来开发
可以看到Triton的性能是明显领先于另外两种的
那这就是我们对它定位就是高效的开发
同时呢能够维持到一个较高的性能
但是如果我们把这个时间拉远
就是说我们尽情的去投入时间去完成算子优化
那就可以看到月底层的这个
算子编程语言
它最后能达到的效能
这个性能就越高
那这个就是我们这个
编程的抽象
以及这个性能和效率之间的关系
那Traden它本身呢
它是一种既包含了
前端的这个算子语言表达
也包含了后面的这个
MR的编辑实现的
完整的一套编译站
然后呢一开始
它是由OpenAI开发的
为的是想兼顾高性能和高运用
来降低这个
GPU Kernel的编程难度
同时呢也是通过这个
与印价无关的算子高效的开发方式
和它同一套算子代码
可以在不同的后端印价上来运行
然后无需复杂的修改
同时呢它也是
采用的是Python类的语法
并没有采用C类的语法
然后呢通过这种套机的编程
提高它的这个编程抽象度
来降低这个算子开发门杆
让这个算子的编写上手更容易
那它的这个整个编译站的过程
大概就是从一开始的语言表达上
会先转换成
MR的一个表达
在这层呢就是Triton R
那这层它其实对于这个
不同的硬件来说
不会有任何的区别
只是一个这个格式上的一个转换
那再往下呢
左侧呢就是
原生社区的这个Triton的实现
它一开始呢会先降低成
这个Triton的GPUIR
在这一层呢
它就会做一些
在对GPU的硬件来说
比较通用的优化
然后再往下呢
在不同的
它其实原生制射两种不同的GPU硬件
那对于这两种硬件来说
它各自会有一套
这个编译的IR
然后呢这样的话
在这层就会对不同硬件做一个分叉
然后来编书
在不同硬件上去运行的二进制
而这种功能呢
对开发
就是对算子的开发者来说
是透明的
因为他们的
只是通过这个
前段的这个Triton language
来完成这个算子的开发
而往后的这些
就由编译信来自动完成
而对于升能来说呢
因为我们这个升能
它是一个NPU
并不是GPU
所以说呢我们从Triton R
往下这层
就会做一个分叉
它会走到这个MR社区的
一个公开的一层
Tensor级的表达
就是Lineal之方言
然后从这层往下呢
我们就会
间接到我们升能专属的一层
IR表达
也就是NPU
那这层呢
就是我们升能推出的
同时也是已经开源的
一个组件
就是
也是属于MR社区的一种组件
然后它呢
目的就是可以支持
不同的前段硬件
都让它在升能上
做一个运行
就之前我们提到的
就开发者
自己没有去完成的那种
跟硬件相关的细节
就会在这一层
给大家做一个自动的插入
最终再编出
运行在升能上的这种二进制
然后呢
整体的这个我们升能主要呢
主要有两个
一个是前段的TradunSend
而一个是后段的TradunUr
TradunSend它的主要功能
就是承担一个前中端的作用
它会对社区的这种开发模式
和所有的接口
来做一个兼容
来保证说我们算子的
这个高效开发和平滑的迁移
比如说如果我们本身
有用Tradun时间的算子
我们使用TradunSend的话
就可以让它在升能上也跑起来
那这层呢
我们对社区的
这种Output的能力
以及这个
Python的这个
记得编译的能力
那其实都做一个兼容
比如说我们算子呢
其实
并不会像C类语言一样
需要我们先通过算子工程
给它编出二进制
然后再去调用
我们直接在这里
就通过这个正常的
Python里边的函数调用
就可以完成这个算子的
自动的编译和运行
它是会跑在内行的时候
把这条代码拿去做一个编译
然后再往下呢
就是TradunData
也是这个TradunSend里的一部分
在这个阶段呢
它就会先做一些
仿存上的优化
比如说仿存的线性化
因为NPU它是一种
CMD的架构
其实它对于这个
仿存连续性
就会有比较高的需求
越连续的仿存模式
在这里呢
在升能上就会拿到
更高的性能
同时它还承担了
这个IR转换的作用
也就是上一页里
提到的过的
这一部分内容
它会完成说
我们的这个IR
然后到SNNPUR的这个转换降级
那最后就是SNNPUR内部
在这一层呢
我们也是会先做一些硬件无关的优化
然后呢
就会做这个升腾强相关的
比如说这个Mix算子试试
然后内存的分位管理
以及同步流水的并行
等等等等这些
最终编译出我们的
这个可在升能上运行的
这个Kernel二进制
通过这套一整个编译站
就是我们这个
这个在升能上的
这个Triton算子的
一个编译流程
就是我们如何支持Triton的
然后往下呢
就是也讲一下说
我们如何去安装使用
当然首先我们在
使用Triton的话
我们第一个第一步
就是需要说
先我们把升能的这个Kern
这个软件包
先完成一个安装
那这个版本对应来说
我们就可以从
我们Triton的这个Kernel三首页
找到我们当前的版本
它对应的Kern社区的版本
是什么样的
然后呢
大家就可以在我们这个
升能的官网上
找到我们这个Kernel三的页面
然后在这里呢
就是选择我们的这个
硬件是哪套产品
我们的CPU架构和
操作系统是什么
然后还有以及我们的安装方式
好
那对于我们Kern的升级来说呢
今天也是提供了在线和离线的安装方式
这种情况下大家可以通过YAM或者Conda
或者离线的这个RUN file来完成
而不是像以前一样
必须需要我们先手动的把这个RUN包下载下来
然后再执行我们的AndreMain
那这里呢大家可以在线安装就可以对于这个Kern的安装效率有一个更好的提升
在我们完成了这个Kernel三之后呢
我们就可以继续安装我们后边的这个Ely和这个TenCent本身
那只要对版本上来说呢
我们要求Python的版本是39到3.11之间的一个版本
大家如果安装的时候
如果大家不是入口用户的话
可以用Konda来封装一个自己的独立环境
或者说那个安装时候用这个GongUser这个选项
同时呢我们在编译的时候呢
一开始我们需要先把PythonEly库给下载下来
那这个Ely库呢
在我们的这个KPython仓是已经做了一个开源
大家在里边可以直接找到
直接通过PPSol-R就可以把这个整个Requirement里边的这个软件都可以安装好
在那之后呢
我们就是需要安装我们的ToshNPU
因为TenCent它毕竟只是算子的一个编写和运行
但我们实际上数据的一些数据化呢
其实还是需要ElyTosh来完成的
所以说我们这个ToshNPU插件也需要我们自己来安装
然后在安装完这个PythonEly以及这个ToshNPU之后呢
我们就可以安装我们的TenCent
那今年的我们对这个TenCent的安装方式
也是做了一个比较大的一个升级
首先是这个一直有的这个PPSol
只用快速安装方式
可以让我们来直接一步到位
就把这个TenCent给装上来
但如果我们对于说圆满游戏改动
比如说有的开发者呢
他其实对于这个里面的编译器
也是有些自己的想法
或者想扩展一些自定义的一些编程的接口
API这些
那他就会对我们这个TenCent的圆满情修改
那圆满情修改之后呢
大家就需要来通过圆满来完成的安装
今天我们就提供了这种圆满的安装脚本
大家可以直接一键执行这个PPSol
更易Python
就可以完成圆满的这个编译和安装
而不是像以前一样需要大家来分好几步
先编LVM或者再编Python的这种方式来完成这个圆满的更新
那这是我们今天做的一个比较大的升级
然后大家一定要注意的就是说
我们安装了看之后呢
一定要手动把sauce在这个set environment的这个脚本来配置环境变量
不然的话我们这个是没法使用里边的这个各种软件工具的
说前面的安装方式呢
我们其实今天还给了这个镜像的安装方式
在Scan枪里呢
我们提供了一个docker file脚本
大家呢
这个可以让
比如大家来安装这个docker的环境镜像
观众中呢
其实我们连看在这里也就是都不需要安装的
在过程里边自动的去从官网里下载对应的版本
我们只需要通过这个build.org里边指定说
比如说是安装在哪套硬件
A2还是A3
还是说后边950
也就是说我们需要装的这个看的版本是什么
但这个对照表大家也是可以从那个观众里面找到
然后后边我们就可以把这个
这个docker run的方式来给这个镜像
给构建
然后再完成一个启动
然后就进入镜像来完成我们的这个算子开发
然后除了前面两种
就是说开发者我们自己来安装Traden
然后自己来体验的话
我们其实今天还提供了一种新的方式
就是开放的平台
就是Hydag Lab
它的链接呢
大家可以从生存的官网里就找到
在这里面呢
大家可以就注册
然后来申请来使用我们这个在线的生存资源
然后这个这个注册成功之后呢
大家在里面可以点击这个TN IDE
然后里面有这个创建环境
里面呢我们可以选择说我们配置的规格
比如说我们什么样的硬件
选择什么样的镜像以及寸数大小
这个镜像里面呢就有我们已经完全封装好的
开箱即用的Traden 镜像
大家只要在里面选择好之后
出现镜像
然后点击连接进去
就可以直接用Traden 来安装
然后不用做任何的额外的安装
就直接可以来做这个算子的一个编写
那这个就是我们今年的几种
不同的TradenSend的安装方式
讲完了我们的基本的底层架构原理以及工具的安装使用之后
我们就来讲一下TradenSend的开发范式到底是什么样的
首先我大概先讲一讲Traden的几类关键的API有哪些
TradenSend它自己的API主要可以分成三组
使用两组是用来做算子的开发
最后一组是做这个Kernel的测试
Traden开发里边这两类的就是一个是Traden
还有类似TradenLanguage
Traden里边的这些API主要是用在TradenKernel以外的部分
比如说我们先说一下常见的四个
首先是TradenGit
这种装饰器它就是用来说指定我的某个函数
它是我们的Traden算子
需要来用我们的Traden的编器来做编译构
可以看到我们后边的算子里边
定义往前一行就会把这个装饰器给放在这里
而后边这个AutoTune和Config呢
这两个其实是一起用的API
它的作用就是来做一个作用的调优
像之前给大家讲过
Traden它是一种跳级的编程语言
对Traden来说它对性能很关键的一点就是说我的这个数据
我是如何做的分款
如何做的并行
这个分款我分了多大
这个分款大小呢
它其实对这个算子性能有非常显熟的影响
但对我们开外来说
我很难直接去判断说
我这个block到底是能够多大
它是最好的
所以呢
Traden也提供了这种自动调译机制
就是AutoTune
里边呢我们就把我们的一些
比如说block side这种的关键的跟性能相关的参数
我们就可以用这个Tradenconfig给包起来
在AutoTune里边呢我们就可以给出一个config的列表
然后在列表里面就看到我们这个比如说我们猜有可能的
比较好的block side可能是1828
也可能是1024
我们把这些我们
觉得有可能的候选我们全都放到这个config列表里面
然后在AutoTune里面呢他就会
给这些所有的config
一个做一个执行和测试
当然他测试不会说只做一遍
他会做测很多遍
然后求平均数
然后呢来找到说我们最好的block size
比如说是最好的config是哪一个
那我们什么时候会触发这种AutoTune的这种
这种evaluation呢
其实就是我们的另一个参数
就是一个key
key这个呢
是我们需要在这里边去写
我们
怎么说呢
需要我们来重运行的
这种参数
比如对算子来说
通常来说这个key的值就会是
我们算子的这个处理数据的总规模
比如说你像我
假如我做一个简单的一个
简简乘除
那我算
我算1万个数的和算10万个数
他们其实最好的block size可能是不一样的
而这个参数值呢就代表说
每当这个key里边的
参数的取值
发生了变化
他就会把所有的config给运行一遍
然后找出来和
这个取值
相匹配的
最好的config
然后他会对这两个之间的关系呢
做一个mapping
然后去然后做一个缓存
这样的话后边
如果我们
后边再次掉的时候
这个xsize取值相同
这样他就不用再重新再跑一次evaluation
会很耗费时间
他可以直接从缓存这边去拿到
对这个size来说
他最好的config是哪种
那这两个是一起用的
API
然后呢还有一种
就是这个hose.seg
他用法其实是一个
对左边这样的一个代替吧
也就是说
我们不是
并不想通过
给对config
来这个
处理说
不同的输入
来做不同的这个block size的设置
我是想
直接指定说
这两个block size
以及这个xsize
之间的一个
数学逻辑上的关系
在这个情况下呢
我们就可以
不用autotun来完成
我们可以直接
通过这个
在这里写一个lambda的一个表达式
来指定说
block size和xsize
它之间的关系是什么
这样的话
如果我们掉的时候
xsize取值发生调整
这会自动找到
最好的这个block size
比如这个例子里边
我们设定的关系就说
是它的这个
下一个RM的
这么一个大小取值
好
那完成了这个
我们说的chernelby的这个API
之后
我们再说一下chernel内里边
我们尝得有哪些
那用在这个chernel内开发的API呢
它会比
上面页的要多很多
总共都有100多个
那它的类别很多
然后涵盖了各种这个
计算的逻辑
那这块我们说一下
几个
几乎是每个算子里面
都会需要的一些接口
首先tensor它本身呢
并不算这个接口
而是一个我们的chernel中
里边
基本的一个数据结构
就说我们提到的
它就是一个pile
然后呢
在我们PineModel这部分
我们第一个
需要了解的就是
ProgramID
这可以理解为是
最重要的一个接口了
因为呢
我们之前说过
我们这个chernel
它我分成了很多的
这个块来做运算
也说呢
它生成了很多这个实力
每个实力计算完成之后
简直说拼成了我们最终的一个
完整的一个结果
但是呢
它是一种spm的方式
就是说我们的所有实力
都是需要了解
我当前这个
实力是第几号实力
才能判断说我要算哪部分的数据
所以说这是一定一个
所有的算子都需要的一个
接口
来判断说我是谁
然后呢
还有一个辅助性的
这个就是
选择性使用了
如果我们需要说搞清楚
我们方向上
我们到底切了多少个实力
就可以通过这个结果来拿到这个结果
然后呢
在这个TensorCrate这块
我们主要用的
有两种
最常见其实第一种
Range这个东西
它会返回
一个halfopen
区间的连续数字
比如说我Range这个08的话
就会返回这个
0123.567
组成了一个Tensor
但我们它的最长的使用方式是什么呢
就是我们再把这个数据
做这个偏外到偏上的搬益的时候
我们就需要拿它来生成一段
连续的
这个offset
然后呢
也就是说如果我们有一个
start point
的一个
这个
我们的地址
我们再加上
通过Range这个创建的一套连续的数据
把这个东西放到这个load里面
才会知道
我要从这个位置开始
去连续
这么多个数据
也就是说
这个也是一个我们最长的
借口之一
另外呢
就还有fu
这个
这个意思就比较直观
而且就返回一个
被标准值填满的Tensor
那它通常会用在哪呢
就是比如说我们想
搞一些这个
一些计算的默认值
就是default value这种
我们就可以通过它来实现
然后最后再往那个对应的位置上去做一个存储
然后最后呢
就是我们的load和store
对
穿着来说呢
其实
我们本身对内存基本上
没有特别明确的感知
只有这个地方是
明确我们在做这种
数据在内存之间的这种准备种操作
它的作用就是说我们把数据从
片外给load出来
放到片上
然后再做我们对应的这个数学的计算
那我们再算完之后呢
我们还要再把
结果再存到
这个片外的内存上
通过这期API呢
我们就可以完成一个
完整的Tent Kernel
那这个呢就是Tent Kernel的一种标准的开发模式
比如说
我们从他的这个逻辑上来看
对任务的完成做法就是我发射很多个逻辑核
那根据我这个逻辑核的数量来把我的这个计算数据切成这么多个block
然后他们直接来做一个并行的计算
那同时因为它是一个
SPMD的开发方式
比如说我所有的逻辑核
我所有的实力
它运行的全都是同一套代码
然后呢我们在单个的逻辑核内
它只是
计算一个block的路具
然后我们所有核的计算结果完成之后
就现在说完成了我们整个的一个计算任务
但也是因为说我们所有的逻辑核都是公共的代码
那对每个逻辑核来说就一定要
搞清楚
这个核的ID是什么
才知道说
那么多
数据切块里我要算的是哪一块
所以说在这个标准的算子内的模式
就是我先
拿到我的这个逻辑核的ID
然后呢
这个block size
也就是我们这个
这个切合的这个大小
其实每次都会通过这个长量传到这个坑中的内部
那么就根据我们的ID和这个block size
来计算出我们对应的
这个数据的偏移是什么
然后找到这个偏移之后
我们同时我们这个数据的
本身那个指针地址也是
通过这个参数给传进来了
这两个放一起
我们就可以找到我们对应的是哪一段数据
然后呢
找到这个数据之后
我们就通过low的这个接口
把它加载到片上的内存
把这些数据加载到片上之后呢
我们就可以
对他们来做这种
数据的计算
然后在完成所有计算之后
我们再把结果
存回片外
那这就是个内的一个完整的实现
那客轮外部呢
我们要做的就是
首先我们
之前提到过
我们的这个输入
是已经在外边创建好了
然后把指针
给传给创建的算子
这样的话在这个算子外部呢
就是我们会
完成这个数据的这个创建和初始化
然后呢
就是
在完成
包括说
其实我们对这个输入的这个内存
也是在外部来完成的
然后呢
我们再把这些
输入楼和指针
全都给传给我们了
穿到扇子
然后有数据之后呢
我们就是要掉这个扇子的kernel
那我们提过这个
给Trendon写Trendon的时候呢
它其实本质上就是发射很多逻辑核来做这个平行的计算
那我们到底发射了多少个核
其实是在down的时候来控制的
在这里呢我们有一个Grid的参数
我们最后发射的核数
其实就是这个Grid的参数的大小
那这就是一个正常的一个社区通用的
Trendon kernel的这种开发的范式
那这里边呢就拿一个最简单的例子
给大家讲一下
实际上我们先看这个算子内的实现
也就是这个接口的使用
实际上我们在外边可以看到
我们会把这个Trendon系的这个装饰器
写在这里来明确的点出
说这个函数就是我们的Trendon kernel
需要把这一段东西放到我们的编译器里边
放到这个Trendon编译器里边去做这个运行
编译还有执行
然后滑上之后呢
在这里边就可以看到我们的参数有哪些
首先是两个输入的指振地址
以及我们输出的这个存储数据这个地址
这些值呢其实都是在我们的片外列寸上的
而不在片上
然后呢这里边还有这个我们的N elements
就是我们整个计算的一个总量
到底有多少数据需要我们来做这个VectorAd
还有就是我们这个切块大小block size
那这就是我们所有的参数
注意到这个block size它是一个长量
然后呢我们看到算子里边的第一步
就是我们也是之前这个上一个也提到过的
就是第一步就是拿这个公文ID来拿到我这个算子ID
那这边我们就来写为这个PID
然后我们有了PID之后呢
我们就给把它
当然对于这个VectorAd它是一个本身来说
这个非常简单算子
我们直接通过把PID跟这个block size乘起来
你就知道在这个所有任务里边
我的这个偏移
也就是说我当前这个计算块的这个起始位置的偏移
是在什么地方
然后我们找到这个偏在起始位置之后
我们再加上通过Range来实现的一串连续的数字
你说它是一串从0开始连续数字
再加上这个block size之后
那这个off size就是一个从block size开始的
长度为block size一个连续的一个数据
补充了一个tensor
然后再往下呢就是我们的把数据
你看到把XOI漏了出来
然后再做一个加瓦
然后再存到这个PID在内存上
但在漏的时候呢
我们要注意还有一个mask的操作
那这部分是为什么呢
就是说我们本身的所有的任务总量
它未必是可以直接被我们的block size整出的
有时候它会有一个尾块
这块呢我们通过这个对这个
我们当前这个off size的一个
off size它是一个完整的嘛
它这个一定是一个完整的
高 size这么长度的一个tensor
如果它呢跟这个NMS这个上线做一个对比
那抛数的部分就会变成0
那通过这个mask呢
就可以保证说我们的尾块
不会把多余的这种脏数据
给搬移到片上内存来做一个处理
然后这样它就可以避免说
我们要么就是漏了多余的数据
我们就做了不该做的运算
就通过这个mask来做一个规避
同时mask的设置呢
相对比较灵活
而传门本身呢也是通过mask的这个自由设置来完成了
这个避散仿存的编写
这些的客户使用大家可以看就是
这个算子的用力呢
它是一个完全这个社区的传门的用力
而红引导实验呢
就可以直接的在生存上来运行
我们的所有的接口的使用都是和社区保持一致的
大家甚至可以直接参考这个社区的这个API文档
然后两个算子内呢我们再来看一看这个算子by的
还有一个完整的这个调用和运行是什么样的
那首先呢一上来我们就是需要
把前提到过这个Touch在我们这是一定使用的
所以我们就需要把这个TouchNPO这个插件给imput进来
然后呢就是把我们Traden的这个库也给imput进来
只要我们先看一个封章的一个Hopper Function吧
那这个Ad呢它并不是
就是它本身其实不是一个Traden的Kernel
但是它在这里边呢
我们就完成对Traden的这个Kernel算子调用
比如说呢
它自己是不需要TradenGeek的
而它里边调用的这个AdKern
就是上页的这个函数
它需要一个TradenGeek的
而这里边呢
它的输入就是我们传给它的
我们XY两个这个需要计算的Tensor
那么我们给它
我们给一个相同的大小来创建这个输出结果的一个空间
然后呢就可以把这个output的这个也传给这个我们的TradenKernel
然后我们可以看见这个算掉的时候
中间有这么一个通过号包起来的参数
也就是Grade
它就是控制了我们切了多少份
用多少个block来完成我们总体的一个计算
好这里边呢
我们也是包菜在这里边
我明确的给了它一个长量的值
但这个Grade取识呢
就是当然我们肯定可以直接写死
比如就写我就要这么多
但也可以通过这种lamb단的方式来写一个计算式
比如说对它来说呢
我们很显然我们所有的这个
我分多少份任务
在乘上我们每份任务里算了多大的这个大小
它全然一定是
或者说这个有一块的话就是超过一些
就一定是相当或超出一些这个n elements的这个大小
所以这块我们就可以直接指定一个除法来计算
说我这个Grade是该如何针对这个block size来做一个取值
那这个就是我们的down的时候来控制它这个多核并行的一个方式
外边呢就是很简单了
就是我们在掉它之前
我们就是需要先完成我们XY的这种方件和数字化
这个就通过这个投射NPU来完成流行
不过这点要注意的是
我们在这条device上要写成NPU
这样它才知道说最后这个东西创建出来之后
它才知道说要把它放到我们的global memory上
这个就是标准的这个finance开发的一个范式
那往后呢我们就要看一下说我们对算来说呢
我们在生存上开发车能算子
跟原生的这种开发方式到底有什么区别
大体来说是没什么区别的
如果在一些细节上呢可能需要有些特定一些注意的点
那这一段呢我们也是结合之前的那个范式的这个讲解
来说一下我们的这个需要关注点有哪些
原生算子内的话呢
我们是可以直接复用原生科学范式
所有的接口的用法也都是一致的
但是呢我们之前也讲过
就是tryden算子实现的涉及到我们把数据给搬到片上再完成计算
这块呢因为我们的这个片内存大小呢
跟其他的硬件有些差异
所以这块呢大家要注意这个内存使用的一个约束
来避免说数据的溢出
在外部呢就是我们虽然创建参数的时候
需要注意来切换给我们NPO对应的接口
把关键词类完成一个替换
另外就是说我们在Grade参数控制之后呢
也是用法跟原始就是一样的
但对于Grade的取值呢
其实在生存上是有些约束
还有些建议的
那下来我们就把这些差一点
给Grade给看一遍
首先是最好调整哈
其实就是说我们用tosh的时候
我们怎么把它来改成在生存上来完成的
做法很简单就是把所有跟硬件相关的这个关键词
来改成NPO就行
那不管是我们说我们创建数据
还是说我们想获得设备
或者当前的这个
或者做一些同步啊返回随机种的这些就是全都是把关键词给设计成NPO就行
这个改动非常的简单
然后呢就该讨论到说我们这个数据
我们是多和平控制的时候
对这个Grade的大小
有什么要求
那实际上应该失去一致点
就是说我们有这是
最多3D的设置方式
如果说你写了更多的
有人写了个5D 6D的
那其实它多出来的部分就是不起作用
所以大家不要那么设置
而且本身Trad的话
我们就是
它的定位上就是一种
易用的开发语言
所以我们其实不希望大家
因为说切了太多的轴
来导致这个算子变得过于复杂
而这个Grade的写法呢
就是我们也比较多
其实就直接往里边写
或者也可以加小括号
或者说在外面定义完
再传进来
这种进入方式都是可以的
但在这个Grade
它其实也体现了说
我们对于哪些轴来做的切分
当然数据本身体现不了
但是我们进去之后
怎么处理Grade这几个维度的值
想说就判定了说
我们在里边
我们对哪些轴做的切分
那么在切的时候呢
我们一定要选择
合适的一个目标轴
尤其是说
我们尽量对高位的轴做切分
尽量不要对尾轴
做这种数据的切分
为了就是说
我们数据可以有更好的连续性
因为声能毕竟是一个
NPO的一个算子
它是一种
CMD的NPO的一个算子
CMD的工作方式
然后在这里呢
如果说我们对于尾轴做一个拆分
那对于每个我们的这个逻辑核的内部的任务来说
它其实数据
就是完全都是不连续的
这种情况下呢
我们的CMD的计算
就有些这个内存资源的浪费
然后另外就是如果说
另一种情况
就是说我们适合拆分的轴呢
太小了
因为我们本身如果核够多的话
那如果我们
Grade设太小了
那其实说就是
我们有些核就闲置了
就没有用上
那这个情况下呢
我们就是
如果说我们真的需要
一些情况下
我们
做这个轴做更多的拆分
我们可以先对这些轴做一个合并
所以把它合成一个更长的轴
然后在这个长轴里边呢
我们在对它做一个虚拟切分之后
等我们其实就是一个
只是一个传递数据的方式
然后我们再把这个数据传给空内之后
我们再把这个一个长度
比如说我们两个轴
给合成一个轴之后
其实这个长度就变成这个
两个轴长度乘起来
进去之后呢
我们再通过这个取域和取摸的方式
就整出和取摸的方式
来找到说我们这个ID在两个方向上
各自的ID是什么
来实现说我们在外边
把两个轴合成一个轴
然后现在我们再拆除这两个轴
这也是一个切分的一个技巧
那除了这个轴的选择以外
我们这个Grid的并行度
也是有一定的要求的
首先是在我们拆的渗子里边
我们的硅的大小是通过一个EU16来描述的
也就是它的本身就存在一个表达的上限
如果我们的硅的设置的数量已经挑出了一个数
那就会给大家报错说你这个硅的设的太多了
然后另外就是说我们这个硅的下降它虽然代表了我们创建的逻辑核的数量
但是呢
这些逻辑核它只是一个广义上的并行
而不是真正的同时来做的执行
那实际上我们的并行能力呢
它是来自于我们物理上的多核
有时它到底能有多少分在同时运算
实际上是取用我们物理的核数
那如果我们设置这个逻辑核数
比我们的物理核数多了很多
那就会出现传型的等待
因为我们只有第一批这个block让所有的物理核同时在计算
那其他的这个block呢就需要等待其中某一个逻辑核的任务完成之后
它再来顶上
而这样的话就会造成比较大的这个硅件的调度开销
影响这个算术最终的性能
而另外一点呢就是说我们逻辑核呢
它是就同一个逻辑核是不能跑在多个人的物理核上的
比如说如果我有40个vector核
但是呢我这里边我只发生了20个逻辑核
它并不会说把这20个给任务再
如果每个任务再给拆开成两份
把它变成40个vector的这个并行
它只会做20个的并行
这样的话另外20个vector核实际上就没有做任何操作
也是有资源的浪费
那cube核也是同理
它并不说我一个坑中里的
它就无法跑在两个cube核上
但是唯一的例外就是混用
因为只要在我们就是啊
比如我们a3这个架构里边
它的cube核和vector的数量是一个1比2的关系
那这个情况下呢就是我们的写一个逻辑核
它如果里边出现的就既出现了我们cube的计算
比如举证成
又出现了一些vector计算
那它就是一种
我们要叫那种cv融合的这种算子
这个c和ve指的是cube核 vector
不是指的那个图像那种
这一般呢就是对这个融合的算子来说呢
它的就可以说我同一个逻辑核里的这个代码可以跑在三个核上
就是一个cube加两个vector这么一个组合的阵容
来保证说我们这个算力来进行大的利用
那如果我们这个逻辑核数量比物理核多的话
那它就是可以串通来执行的
那通过这个那我们就可以看得出来
我们对硅的取值呢
其实最好就是直接跟我们这个物理核的数量取一个相当的数量
最多是你可以有些在基础上有些微调
然后那对于政策来说
那我们car者该怎么来找到我们这个物理核数呢
那这里边我们也提供了对应的接口
比如说我们就通过这个gevactive这里边的找到这个guide device property
找到我们这个当前这个硬件上我们这个cube和vector他们的核数到底是多少
然后再访问这个我们叫numAI call
就可以找到我们这个cube callcube核的这个数量
如果我们在这边访问这个numvector call
它就会返回我们这里边这个vector核的数量
那这两个的结果在A3上也是一个EBR的一个关系
对那讲完我们这个guide的这个多控制之后
那下边就是要讲到这个内存相关的了
所以这块先快速过一下这个生存运件的架构
这边也是先拿A3的来做个例子
我们在生存里边呢计算单元主要有三种
第一种就是做矩阵的cube计算单元
还有第二种就是做向量的这个vector运算单元
那它俩呢就分别在这个cube call和vector call里边
而在这两个核里边呢
他们各自都会配一个scaler这种标准运算单元
来帮他们处理一些这个一些非矩阵
非向量的这种运算
比如说一些数据的准备
一些地址的运算
或者一些逻辑的运算
然后呢存储单元呢是在cube核里边要负载一些
首先是数据从外边的global memory进来之后
先进到这个通的存储的LE buffer
这块呢它也除了说内部同存储以外
它还可以说暂存中间的一个结果
然后呢就是我们到数据就会进到这个L0的A和B这两个buffer
那我们pcube核毕竟是0点就是左牛矩阵的运算
那这块呢就是放我们的矩阵A和矩阵B
那完成运算之后
它的数据就会存到这个L0C buffer上
这个buffer之后它就会可以选择说
我是存回LE还是说直接存出GM
那这个就是cube核里的一些计算单元
那vite核呢计算单元就相对比较简单一些
其实就是一个unified buffer
简称ub
数据呢就是说我们先load进来放到ub上
然后vite核才可以对它做一个运算
运算的结果也是自动的存储到这个ub上的
好那讲完之后呢我们就来看一下说我们pn内存的使用上有哪些要注意的点
这也是刷在本身的写法上的要求就是我们的数据一定要搬到片上在进行计算
但是呢这块我们搬过来之后呢对这个pn内存的使用呢是要注意不能超过它的大小的
那如果说我们比如说来了一个很大的block size
它就是太大了就是把这个pn内存称爆了
那我们要怎么做呢
首先如果说我们增加这个并行数量
对就是说增加这个grid数量
它肯定是能对应的把box缩小
那这样的话呢我们之前提到过了
grid它其实也是有这个曲折建议的啊
建议和伪合一致
所以说在这里我们就不能简单的去把这个block size去做一个缩小啊
让它放到进这个内存
那这是第一点
刚才就说我们在里边放送的时候
要注意说我们建议说如果我们放送在ub上
或者说比如说我们对它是来做一个vector计算
我们就要注意32b的对齐
如果是放在矩阵那边呢
就是kabel核里边就要注意是这种512b的对齐
好之前也说了很久的这个我们pn内存和边上内存
它们分辨是什么呢
我们pn内存在升等上就是global memory
也就是商业的gm
而我们的边上内存呢指的就是说
LE buffer还有这个unified buffer就是一个ub
所以我们数据呢都是说
我们的load其实就是把数据从这里搬到LE或者是这个ub
具体搬到哪里其实就编辑器来做一个自动的判断
它会根据这个计算的内容来识别它的数据应该在的位置
然后呢但是这里边我们也要注意就是说
我们对这个适应的处理方式一般来说
就是增加一个参数就是subblock也就是二级切分
再说我们把这个block size呢我们在算子内呢我们切的更小
让进行更小的小块然后让小块呢来挨个的做完成的计算任务
这样保证呢就是我们通议时间
这个block里呢我们使用的内存就只有这一小块
这样的话就可以避免这个数据的一个溢出
但是我们比如说我们到底这个里边的二级切分大小该切多长
这个怎么办呢啊首先是我们第一点就是我们不建议大家
我这个算子本身的实现来这个人工的估算
我大概感觉啊用了多多大的内存
然后来调整我这个啊力表二级切分的大小
因为首先呢我们有很多的空间呢是展播很多
有一部分空间会留给啊比如说中间变量
或者留给这个接生器来用
比如说这部分呢呃内存使用呢对todo来说是不可见的
比如说会出现说比它预想的格外的一些啊占据空间的东西
另外呢还有一部分呢就是说我们啊本身编辑是自在那种内存服用的能力的
比如说里边里边可能放进了很多的tensor啊
但实际上呢它如果编辑识别出来说这两个的生命周期不一致
它就会做一个内存的一个服用
所以这样的话呢它的最后实际实际使用的空间呢
可能会比你估算的又小一些
那也是因为这个原因呢就是说啊我们直接希望大家就可以直接你就是随便写个然后就开始跑一板
那如果它跑成功了那说明这个我这个呃数据这个这个这个内存没有没有给用溢出啊
甚至你还可以再给这个东西再调大一些啊如果说溢出了那么就可以直接读它的这个编辑的报色提示
在报线提示里面呢
他会给我们讲说
我们你当前这个写法
它造成了在哪块内存上的移除
那你当前写法
它需要多大的大小
但是我们当前呢
这个表现内存能提供多大的大小
大家就可以根据这两个数字来调整
根据他们之间的这个比较的关系
来调整我们对用的这个二级切笨的大小
同时大家要在用的时候也要注意说
不要跑过就行
因为如果你这个切得太小了
它也能过
但是呢这样的话就是会造成这个性能的浪费
所以大家就是在尽可能
用满一个核内的内存的情况下
来给它调整一个二级的切分
然后呢用法也很简单
我们只需要在里边多加一个循环
给偏移呢这个类似多加一层的一个偏移的控制
就可以完成说我先算一个subblock
然后循环里边就再算完一个
这样保留说同一时期
不会有两个subblock在同时搞任务
那这个就是我们内存使用上的一个技巧
好 接下来拿一个算子来给大家展示一个实践
我们用的就是这个guided的算子
那这块我们用的例子呢是一个行
行角度的一个guided
那这边我们假设说
我们每行这个数据都非常的大
它单行就可以造成这个数据的溢出
然后在下边呢
我们会根据这个ID来把对应的这个行拿出来
然后存到对应的一个按数据存到这个对应的位置上
那这是它这个算子的本身的一个逻辑
那这个关注点就是说我们首先
我们每一个
首先我们第一点就是我们要把这个guided数量设置和这个物理核一致
那这样的话在我们如果这个行数一多
那肯定会有
有的物理核会处理这个布置一行
这块呢我们就把这个行数分给这个多核的时候
要注意说尽可能要分的平均
另外的就是行内
在我们这个本身一行已经耗出了这个内存大小的情况下
我们就要对这个行内做一个telling
让它说先算完一小块
再算完同行的另一块
就完成整行的一个内存的一个
但这块guided就是一个内存搬移了
不涉及太多的计算
那实际上话第一步啊
第一步肯定我们就是先搞清楚
我们这个当前的版本到底有多少核可以让我们用
就是我们的guided到底能射中多大
就可以通过这个接口来导出来对那数据
然后呢晚上之后呢
这个看啊
这个函数它是一个辅助的函数
它其实要算的就是说我们在帮我们
也不算帮我们吧
就是我们写它就是为了辅助说计算
说我的可动里边的这些参数
我要怎么算出它们
然后就在这些外边来完成
这边呢我们就会啊
首先拿到我们这个核数
来作为这个guided的一个取值
然后呢我们也会说
在这里边把这个任务来平均的分给不同的物理核
然后做法其实就是我们直接这个通过一个整图
然后就可以找到啊
我们该每个核应该分多少行
那其中一部分核呢
它的分的行会比别的核要多一行
那这一部分呢我们就可以叫它
big row
如果少一行呢
那就是啊就没有名吧
就是多一行就是big row
然后呢
找到这个之后呢
我们就可以啊
用这个算子调用来把我们这个核数给传进去
然后呢还有一些说我们里边
我们这个到底有多少个多一行的这么一个核的任务
然后另外就说我们这个分块的时候啊
它每一块大小是什么
那这块就是我们啊
要传给这个这个客户的一个信息
但这块就也包括说我们啊
每个核出去多少行
以及每一列上啊
这一列我们前面要起成什么样的
那算子内部呢
时间就啊
现在就要啊
怎么说呢
啊
虽然行数多
但也比较直观啊
第一步呢
就是我们也是啊
根据这些内容
我们要找到我们这个核的idea多少
也就是搞清楚我这个实例
要完成的是哪几行的该的任务
然后呢
接下来呢
我们就可以根据我们这个当前的这个这个核的这个id呢
来跟我们这个bcorenum做一个比较
来搞清楚说啊
我这个核它是多一行的还是少一行的
然后呢
找到这个确定下来这个70D之后呢
我们再啊
就可以怎么说呢
先是一个综合的这么一个
呃
来判断说我这个核的任务需要搞多少行
再往后呢
就是说根据我这个行数呢
以及我当前核的id来找到说
我这个核处理的任务的行号的起始行号是在哪里
那里边呢
就需要做一个判断
来完成说我们这个行便宜的一个计算
我们再找到说我们要算哪几行之后
那里边就是
呃
就是一个两层循环了
啊
其实逻辑也比较简单
一个是从略的角度啊
因为我们跑过它的上键
所以我们就需要来这块做一个循环来啊
呃
依序的把里边的小的subblock给完成运算
然后呢
在行的角度呢
其实就是我们啊
每个核也分这么多行
我们也不可能说啊
一次
一个任务完成很多的行
这些不现实
因为它本身一行就已经超大小了
那这块呢
我们就是啊
就直接简单的通过逐行的方式
来完成数据的处理就行
然后边呢
也有时候我们如果说啊
有一nif
啊
设的
设的这个是服役的话
我们就来啊
给它填上我们的这个
不如画的这种默认数据
那这也是啊
算的一部分
那这就是一个整体的一个
该的算的一个实现流程啊
就是说大家注意
注意好这个数据的划分
以及这个啊
内存的使用
在进行用满内存情况下
我们来啊
把这个数据来提高它一个
就最好是内存用的越满越好
然后呢
明星度也用的越好越好
就明星度也用的越满越好啊
但是不要超过物理核太多
啊
然后最后一部分呢
也是那个
再细讲一下
我们这个
AutoTone的这个能力
那这边
首先我们先说AutoTone本身的用法哈
哈
他已经提到过
说我们的这个
Key的值里边
这个关键值
它的这个参数
它的取值
一旦发生变化
就会触发里边
所有的config的一个
一个测试
来选出最好的
但是我们在用的时候呢
有一点要注意就是说
这个BlowSize
如果我们把它已经
把它选择在
放在config里边
做一个作用
调优的一个参数
那我们就不需要把它
来放在我们的算子
down的时候
比如说我们这个
add kernel
之前给大家看过了
BlowSize
其实它的一个最后一个参数
一个长量的参数
但是如果说我们
在这个算子
使用了AutoTone
比如说我们让它
自动来
帮我们测试
并且挑出来
最好的BlowSize
以外
那这个
从逻辑上来说
我们确实就
不需要再把这个值
给传进去了
因为它不会用
我们这里的值
它会用这个AutoTone
给搞出来的值
所以说这个时候
我们电用算子的
就注意说
最后一个参数
就不要写里边
当然定义里边
还是有的
但是在down的时候
是没有这个参数的
如果你真的写了
它反正会给你
报一个错误
跟你说
你有这个参数的
一个符合的定义
就是用AutoTone
一个注意点
另外就是
它还提供了
就是三种
就是进一步
来使用的功能
那首先就说
如果我们这个
config列表
它可能是
从别的地方
布置过来的
或者里边
有太多的config
需要来测试
但我们又不想
它的这个测试
时间过久
那么就可以通过
以及它提供的
函数和结构
来先把一些
不太可能
或者一些
标准之外的
给去掉
比如说
我可以通过
perfmodel
来指定一个函数
作为我的一个
形成模型
就是说这个
perfmodel
它会给
这个
普通的config
来做一个打分
它并不会运行
它只是直接
根据这个config
来做一个打分
但具体的
那个实现
是开发者
自己来定的
然后呢
就是topk
就是在我
前面perfmodel
完成了这个
打分情况下
我设定个
topk的参数
来就是说
我的config里边
我只保留
topk的
分高的
就是通过这个模型
来判断出
分高的config
来做后面的
这个evaluation
就是说
如果我这个
config里表里
写了十个config
但这topk呢
我写了四
那实际上
后面做这种
evaluation
来做这个实地测试的
实际上就只有
其中的四个config
另外呢
我们也有这种
而对于config
可以通过一些曲折的范围
直接指定
比如说我这个blow size
好过多大的
我就是不测了
觉得它不可能
就通过这种
这几种函数
或者这几种
那个参数的作用呢
就是来帮我们提前
修剪掉一些
不太现实
或者说我们
觉得
那不太可能成为
这个最优结果的
这些config
然后呢
还有后来两个
也是非常重要的
这个对算子来说很重要
就是reset to zero
还有resolve value
这个看名字就很明显
它的作用是什么
一个是说
我每次评估前
把它这个参数的列表
给同质为零
或者说呢
每次在完成平均后
再把这个
处置列表给
就是这个处置值
给恢复成
这个我跑它之前的值
那这些一般什么的会用呢
比如说我
如果我这个trade算子
它是一个累加
比如说呢
我并不说
比如说srv等于z
我是给x做累加
然后呢
这样的话
如果我们的config测试的时候
它在跑完滴溜的时候
这个x值已经是
互相的变化
那往后的
其实后边所有的
计算的内容
就已经
不是我们想要的了
甚至如果里面有分支的话
它甚至会跑到不同的分支
跟我们的预期不符
那我们就通过这种
reset或者resort的方式
我们比如说我们如果加了resort
那我们希望每次这个x算完之后
它会恢复成我们做了一家之前的值
那如果你不加这个参数的话
它就会x值就会越来越大
然后甚至最后可能会超过这个表达的上限
那这个就是我们算调的时候
一些更多的一些参数细节
然后这边看到有科学者有提问
就是Grid的数量一般多少合适
而Grid的数量我们推荐
就是跟我们的物理核数量给保持一致
那具体物理核数量呢
对于普通的这个硬件版本是有区别的
所以说呢我们这块也是向大家通过
这个我们提供的这个接口
来查询我们的物理核的数量
然后那就可以把这个物理核的数量
设置为我们的Grid的大小
我也可以在基础上做微调
这也就跟我们这个算的它这个本身的实现有关系了
但是整体逻辑就是把它设为这个物理核的大小
然后呢这个今天技术内容呢就讲到这些
然后呢再讲一下我们后边这个跟之前提到过了
这个Traton在我们生产上做使用的时候呢
其实里边是接着两个组件
那这两个组件呢我们也都分别做了一个开源
那其中一下我们的Traton Center
在今年其实已经放到了原生的Traton Lounge这个社区里边
是一个也是一个独立开源仓
在这块呢大家是也是一个后边的这些互动啊
或者说一些比如想做一些代码提交
其实都可以在这个仓里边完成
然后呢NPR呢这个仓呢
它还在我们这个Gitcode
这个Asun的组织下面
这个就是组件就是我们提到过的
它提供的就是我们给各种前端的这种通过的编程语言
来提供一个那样升堂的自动的一个亲和优化
然后这两个仓的访问二维码呢
也提在这里吧
大家可以直接通过扫码来进入到这个仓的链接
也欢迎大家
如果觉得这个还可以的话
也可以欢迎大家来点个新
然后呢我们对于生态工件上呢
我们其实也做了这个比较完整的生自然体系
我们两个仓都匹配了比较完备的本档的资料
和里边一些优秀的时间的案例
以及我们还提供了一些开发上的线上的课程
包括说现在看的训练营这种直播课程
同时呢我们也有这个技术活动和交流的平台
有这个社区论坛
然后和训练营
以及或者我们有时候会有办一些线下的me time活动
包括我们这个社区上
我们也成立了这个四个组织
这也会定期双周的来开一个例会
大家在这边呢
我们的所有的每天都会上线
大家在这边可以看到我们最新的这个技术的进展
以及说一些我们外部对我们的一些需求
然后另外大家参与的时候呢
可以说通过我们四个来参与
或者给我们两个社区来贡献代码
或者写文档也可以
在这个逐渐过程中呢
大家可以逐渐来承担我们社区里的关键角色
比如说逐渐的从一个供献者变成committer
是作为这个社区的maintainer
都是可以的
我们有一套完整的进程流程
那么四个交流群组呢
大家可以通过扫这个码
来加我们的这个小助手
来进入我们的这个交流群
后续如果大家有这个技术上
或者说后续的发展方向上的一些提问
其实都可以通过这个群来完成
那结果稍微停留一下
让大家可以扫满
好
就前面我们介绍过这个参与的这个玩法1
已经有小伙伴在这个一休音乐底下评论答案了
本次互动直播互动的三道题的答案呢
是BAD
所以评论区呢
全部答对的前五名小伙伴
可以私信我们的生存小助手
来领取奖品
当然那个没有抽到奖品的小伙伴
也不要灰心
我们还有科后的作业
还有学习笔记
都有机会拿到奖品
大家也可以扫码报名
看训练营
来
就会有更多的挑战
还有丰富的奖品
来等待着大家
大家也可以扫描屏幕上这个二维码
来预约下一场直播
然后如果有梅拉级观看直播的开发者呢
可以在B站搜索
升上看
来观看回放
那以上就是这个今天
马力全开特辑的直播全部内容
我们下期再见